nous venons de vivre un week-end
dramatique et pour cause la violence à
Sainte-Soline a atteint des sommets dont
on peut craindre qu'elle puisse
éventuellement se renouveler ce que nous
ne souhaitons pas
des forces de l'ordre des gendarmes ont
été blessés nombreux
cela est inacceptable naturellement
d'ailleurs il faut saluer leur travail
ainsi que celui de la préfète qui a
piloté les opérations mais
cette montée de violence elle est venue
ailleurs sous d'autres formes on a
dégradé à un moment des œuvres d'art
on a également
bloquer la circulation manifestée créer
des tensions extrêmement fortes
y compris avec des risques de conflits
réels
dans deux ans la France organise des
jeux olympiques de 2024 dès l'année
prochaine la Coupe du monde de rugby
monsieur le ministre on nous a indiqué
que tout ce travail était en préparation
vous êtes venu vous exprimer récemment
devant la commission de la culture ainsi
que la commission des lois au regard de
ce que nous vivons en ce moment et de
cette montée de violence inacceptable
comment êtes-vous en train de préparer
cette opération avec quels moyens et
surtout à quel moment déposerez-vous un
texte devant le Parlement pour que nous
puissions légiférer je le pense en tous
les cas au plus vite